welcome to my new home for a couple of
days maybe three who knows there are
plenty of ways to pass the time martin's
getting good at solitaire alcohol has
been my friend over the last couple of
days but what april lewis really wants
to do is pass a test i honestly truly
thought that it would be a piece of cake
lewis and her partner were making their
way back home from palm springs planning
to cross the border into canada on
saturday they were aware they needed a
negative covet 19 rapid test results in
order to do so but what they didn't know
is just how difficult it would be to get
one we went to a couple of pharmacies
they said you have to pre-book but they
said even if you do pre-book we don't
have any product there is no product in
watkin county the couple scoured the
city striking out even at the airport
lewis then reached out to her mp who
managed to find an appointment roughly
30 minutes away in birch bay the only
catch it's for tuesday and so they wait
gave myself a manicure gone for walks
did i mention alcohol i think i did are
we the first person that this has
happened to the federal government is
testing requirements at the border
crossings for fully vaccinated travelers
late last month and while rapid antigen
test results are now acceptable those in
the tourism and business sector say the
protocols are not the clear strategy for
the federal government is to remove all
of these testing requirements for fully
vaccinated travelers we've been calling
on it and now april lewis's as well mr
trudeau if you're listening
i am triple vaxxed what more do you want
my firstborn child i mean police but
more than anything she hopes her story
serves as a warning particularly for
families heading into spring break
please be aware do your homework do your
research on monday lewis and her partner
managed to cross the border she found a
test she passed it but after two nights
and three days stranded i've been
waiting for martin to play crib with me
but he won't passing the test of time
was the hardest part kylie stanton
global news